welcome back so in this short video I'm going
to talk about the art of the possible in machine
learning so specifically trying to give you case
studies of the development of the capabilities
of machine learning over the last 10 years and
this kind of moving goal post of what is easy
medium and hard in the field of machine learning
so we call this the art of the possible this is
continually unfolding continuously changing and
what I'm going to do is go through a number of
little vignettes and examples of problems that
used to be hard for machine learning and now are
easy and set up some of the problems that are
still hard that we hope will be you know more
possible to solve more easily in the future
so I'm going to jump right in this is broadly
speaking we're talking about General Topics in
applications of machine learning so image Sciences
audio sequences natural language processing not
so much engineering applications but we'll get to
those soon so there there's this nice XKCD comic
you know when a user takes a photo the app should
check whether they're in a national park this
is an idea for an app someone's thinking about
okay so the programmer says sure easy uh you know
geospatial lookup give me a few hours okay so easy
to tell from a photo whether or not they're in a
national park and the app should check whether the
photo is of a bird okay I'll need a research team
in five years so this is a joke that um you know
some problems are trivially easy if you have the
right data if you have this kind of geotag other
tasks might be full-on research level projects
you know five years and a team of researchers
now what's funny is that this comic is not that
old and when this comic was made telling whether
or not the photo has a bird and it was a hard
problem a hard research problem that would need
a team in five years now telling if a photo
has a bird and it is trivially easy this is
commodity off-the-shelf machine learning it's
in all of our phones right now basically so in
a very short amount of time uh kind of this
meta this comic becomes more interesting in
that medicines but that's really what I want to
get to today is what are things that are easy
medium and hard and things that are easy now
might have been hard only five years ago okay
so facial recognition and image recognition
in general is one of these fields that in the
last 10 years has went from being kind of the
frontier challenge to being a solved problem uh
broadly speaking in machine learning so you can
very accurately tell uh if an image has faces
and you can classify who those faces belong
to so we just went to our daughter's School
Musical and my wife held up her phone to take
a picture of all of the hundred people in the
cast and in real time immediately it saw from
this tiny tiny image which one was our daughter
and recognized her out of all of these people
in real time that's essentially a solved task
10 years ago that was the frontier
of modern machine learning research
um the reason this has essentially become a solved
problem is because of the development of imagenet
and the the training of a deep neural network to
solve the imagenet classification problem in the
2010 to 2012 time frame where essentially and
and what I want to point out almost all of the
attention goes to the imagenet trained neural
network that actually classified all of these
images that essentially was a neural network
model to classify all of these images into their
various categories in my opinion the real hero
of this revolution 10 years ago where we got a
human level classification performance on with a
machine learning model was actually because of the
imagenet data set in 2009 so this was feifei Lee's
group and essentially they put together this very
very large labeled training data set um I believe
it was you know millions of images thousands of
categories many many examples per category of
hand labeled training data that then enabled
the training of the imagenet neural network and
so both of these are important but it all started
with this painstakingly meticulously labeled
training data so I think that's a really important
thing for us to remember is it usually all starts
with the data and then training the model I would
say you know the neural network that built the
classifier was inevitable once that training
data set was on the market now what has happened
yeah why was this possible in in the 2010 time
frame to make such a big leap in training neural
networks just a couple of years before nobody
was talking about neural networks as a serious
machine learning Paradigm all of uh industrial
machine learning was essentially decision
trees support Vector machines things like that
frame there was this rapid acceleration of
compute power especially parallelized compute
power in the form of graphics processor units
that are very well suited for neural networks
there were dramatically better algorithms to
train and optimize the the weights of these neural
networks to fit the training data in that time
period and a huge amount of Industry investment
into the open source software and pipelines
like tensorflow and Pi torch again around
um you know around the last 10 years and this
culmination of a massive massive increasingly
large data sets high performance Computing
better algorithms to train these models and
Industry investment have really been the Catalyst
that has caused this huge acceleration of machine
learning we've seen in the last 10 years and
this is where most people would say that the
modern era of machine learning started was this
imagenet breakthrough in image classification
there are still issues with automated
classifications so you know the blueberry
Chihuahua or the Fried Chicken Dog are two
kind of good examples where you know maybe
it's not perfectly able to classify all of these
images but I would argue that you know definitely
humans don't have perfect ability either okay
and this is more uh just a joke to show kind of
things have gotten so far that you really need to
look at edge cases before these algorithms even
remotely break down so image classification was a
major breakthrough you know just over 10 years ago
surveillance then became a Target because it's
easy to classify images but moving sequences of
images movies it's a lot more data so it's a lot
more data intensive to process that in real time
now surveillance is essentially a solved problem
it's easy to segment images in real time into
different components and track objects and tell
what changes and what's novel things like that
um generative images was a big push in the last
10 years as well so the left column these are
real images kind of the left and third column are
real images and the second and fourth column are
computer generated versions of those uh those
categories so these are all fake flowers fake
Harvesters and fake broccoli and unless you look
really closely and zoom in it actually does a
really good job of kind of fooling at least your
broad sense if I look at it out of the corner of
my eye these do look like uh you know tractors
and Harvesters and things like that you have to
look closely before you can see that they're
actually not real and this one's even better
this image is at least five years old
things have gotten way way better in
the meantime for image generation now
we have deep fakes you can completely
generate a fake uh movie of a person that's
pretty um hard to tell fake from reality
and again about five years ago image captioning um
became kind of an interesting topic so you would
show a picture to one of these machine learning
algorithms and it would try to come up with a
sentence that summarized or captioned the image
and you can see here it does a really good job man
in black shirt playing guitar it's definitely a
man in a black shirt playing a guitar construction
worker in Orange safety vest working on road
and so on and so forth but in 2017 it wasn't
perfect there were plenty of examples where it
failed miserably this is not a young boy holding
a baseball bat this is the ugliest cat I've ever
seen and there is no horse to speak of standing in
the middle of the road okay so not perfect Circa
2017 but again in that last five years something
that was hard has become dramatically easier to
the point that this is almost a solved problem
We are now working on the inverse problem... so
taking a prompt or a sentence, machine learning
algorithms like DALL-E can now generate very very
compelling original images that fit the caption.
Okay, so DALL-E 2... I started playing around with
this over the summer, just typing in
random prompts, and I didn't do anything special
to get these amazing images: "Guitar monnster"
and "a cat submarine chimera". These are the images
that DALL-E generates just from those prompts
And I'll point out uh there are two "N"s here because
my old laptop the "N" key stuck, so I think that the
double "N" is essential for the texture of this
guitar monster... but all joking aside, if you think
about how impressive this is... this is a very
cool artist rendition of a monster playing theguitar
notice that the guitar is also a monster...
it's really a guitar double "N" monster... Very verycool.
So something that was unthinkable five years
ago is now a commodity.
You can log on to DALL-E 2 and do this yourself right
now, today.
It's very very cheap to generate an image from a textsequence.
So it used to be impossible, now it's easy.
And this is the trend in pretty much all of image
sciences. This is actually from 2019
Samsung Skolkovo Institute of Science and
Technology collaboration where they essentially
showed you could take a single still image like
the Mona Lisa and you could essentially do this
this transfer learning, and kind of texture
transfer, where now you can make this come to life
as if the Mona Lisa was speaking. So 2019... pretty
recent, but also a lot has happened since then.
I like to think about this... if I go back
in time, I remember when Google came out with
their deep dream which was this deep generative
dream; before all of this technology I
just showed, you where it would make these really
weird pictures... you could take an image and kind of
decompose it and recompose it so it was made out
of geckos or lizards or puppies or flowers and it
harkens back this idea to this Archimbaldo's La
Primavera... so he was around in uh the 1600s, he was
in Emperor Rudolph II's Court, essentially
supported by that dynasty and it's this really
interesting idea that you can decompose a complex
image into its abstract pieces, and now this is
something that is relatively standard capability
with machine learning, is to transfer the texture.
uh over so you could paint this in the style
of Van Gogh or any any famous painter you like.
and so we're thinking about this this is kind
of the deep dream of of this archimbaldo's La
Primavera by Calhoun press I really like this if
you actually download this uh GIF and and pause
the frames you'll see that there are you know
different decompositions of this in terms of like
peacock feathers or puppies or things like that
and so one of the open problems today one of the
things we're actively active research that's hard
today that we hope is going to be easy in five or
ten years is the same idea of kind of texture
transfer we want to start applying to physical
systems like fluid flows and Engineering Systems
so here I have a really uh low Reynolds number
simple simulation of a simple fluid flow past an
obstacle past a circular cylinder this is our you
know warm-up Benchmark problem in fluid dynamics
to compute lift and drag and things like that
and with commodity off-the-shelf algorithms
you can do a texture transfer I can re-paint
this picture in the style of famous artists and
so that's easy what we want to do is we want to
repaint this fluid flow in the texture of a much
higher Reynolds number fluid flow so what I want
to do is I want to know from this base image what
would the flow look like if I cranked up the flow
velocity to something that is realistic for an
aircraft or if I cranked up the Mach number to
something that's realistic of an aircraft that's
much harder to do and we not only want to do it
so it looks good to the eye we want it to be
quantitatively accurate as well so for example
we want you know Mass momentum and energy to be
conserved when we do this style transfer and so
that is currently hard today but researchers
across the world are working on solutions to
do that for fluid flows for materials for all
kinds of physical systems where we have both f
equals ma physics and we have lots of training
data where we might actually have examples of
this flow at low speed and high speed to do that
that transfer pardon today hopefully not tomorrow
lots of other things that are difficult for uh
for computers so I was showing you lots of image
examples there's also natural language and text
and speech and things like that so I think the
Next Great American novel is going to be something
that will be quite challenging for an AI agent to
generate I think it's unlikely for a computer
to have the kind of deep insights into society
that for example F Scott Fitzgerald could have had
in his era unless that AI has a body and has the
ability to go and interact um that's not to say it
can't generate some types of fiction we don't know
um who knows maybe in five years this will become
much easier than I thought it would be maybe it's
still going to be much harder than we thought
it would be we don't know but you know writing
the Next Great American novel I'm gonna be um you
know cautiously pessimistic about that capability
this is actually a machine learning generated
fan fiction for Harry Potter so they took a
bunch they took all of Harry Potter and
they took a bunch of fan fiction and
basically generated an algorithm that would
generate new fan fiction Harry Potter text
um it's not terrible it's not very good but it's
not terrible you can always pause this and read
some of the lines are awful some of them are
actually kind of cute Ron's Ron shirt was just
as bad as Ron himself I don't hate that that's
not bad but you know there's still a long way
to go and this was a couple of years ago earlier
than that it was shown that you actually can use
um kind of these generative algorithms to build
fake conference papers academic papers that would
get accepted to top journals and conferences
and so it's unclear to me if this says more
about the machine learning algorithms or more
about the state of academic publishing but
there are absolutely you know anything
that is really rigid and formulaic and
structured like writing an academic paper you
have more of a shot of being able to automate
and train an algorithm to kind of recognize
those patterns and regenerate those patterns
examples just in a very recent time chat GPT and
large language models have kind of revolutionized
the art of the possible dramatically advancing
our ability to generate human consistent natural
language in a way that is much much faster than
we thought would be possible we being kind of
the general Community I think it surprised
most of us so here's a cool example I got
from from Bing Brunton there's this famous
Samuel Taylor College poem about Xanadu
and Xanadu did Kubla Khan a stately pleasure Dome
decree where Alf the sacred River ran through
Caverns measureless to man down to a sunless sea
beautiful little stanza of a poem now the way The
Story Goes Samuel Taylor Coleridge wrote this
down just before falling into an opium stupor
and when he woke up he couldn't remember the
rest of the poem so this is a famous unfinished
poem and lots of people have speculated how
this might go what it could have been like
some researchers ran this through chat GPT 3 and
it actually completes the poem in the stat the
style of college starting with this prompt and
again it's not perfect but it's really not bad
at all you can pause this and you can read it
yourself but this is a major breakthrough these
large language models are a major breakthrough in
the capabilities of the art of possible with with
natural language processing and human realistic
generative text and this is likely going to change
many many of our daily Pursuits right if you want
to write a technical manual this can help write
that technical manual faster if you want to write
unit tests for your codes or Auto documentation
for your codes this is going to help do that
faster this is uh helps us write emails faster
auto complete codes as a kind of co-pilot tons
and tons of things and we're just scratching the
surface of what these large language models are
capable of and again this slide is only a couple
of months old already out of date right now we're
on to gpt4 and these are only going to increase in
their complexity and sophistication in the years
to come so something that was really really hard
um a couple of years ago now it's
accelerating at really rapid pace
okay large language models huge huge field
moving to other systems I think this is kind
of interesting there is this more of X Paradox
which is it's easier to build a Computing system
that will beat a human at chess than it is to
actually pick up the chess piece and move the
piece dexterously across the board so I think
there's an example of you know a competition
between a boy and a computer chess agent and the
computer chess agent also had a robotic body that
would move the chess pieces and um at some point
it accidentally broke the kid's arm and you know
that's how the game ended not because it beat it
at chess but because it was so horrifically bad
at moving the pieces that it kind of disqualified
itself uh through gross bodily harm so things AI
is good at it's good at math it's good at games
now it's very good at language things it is not
good at yet are sensing and interacting with the
world and so there's this idea that you know this
kind of AI brain it definitely is developing the
capabilities are advancing rapidly but the kind
of body side of things are not advancing nearly
as quickly robotics you know super exciting area
lots of progress but the advances in the robotic
body are not happening as striking or as fast as
the advances in the the kind of robotic mind
and I think this is going to be in the future
a big distinction is that there are certain
things you need to interact with the world
to gather the information to be curious to really
enrich your models Beyond math games and language
we'll see again currently hard maybe in five
years this will be easier than we think it is
and there's a a lot of good examples of machines
being very very good at games so 2015 there were
these extremely Advanced demonstrations of
reinforcement learning by deepmind essentially
a deep neural network Q learning algorithm showed
that it was possible to play most old Atari games
at or above human level performance this was
pretty impressive so this is a classic game
I think it's called block out where essentially
it's like pong but it's a one player pong and
you're trying to break this rainbow array of
Bricks by bouncing this this dot back and forth
so you know after a few minutes of
game play it can play poorly but it
can at least you know hit the hit the ball
with the paddle you know moderately often
after two hours it is very reliably able to
position the paddle to hit the ball and it's
able to you know eventually get a respectable
score in this fairly repetitive task game
um you know it's doing probably better than
I could do with a similar amount of practice
what I think is remarkable though is after
four hours of training that's not a lot of
training right like when I was a kid
I would play four hours in one sitting
it learned something that only expert humans get
which is that if it just drills this left side
here watch it it's just really trying to focus on
this left side over here if it drills this left
side then the physics of the game take over and
solve the problem for it that is in my opinion an
actual kind of interesting Innovative leap in the
learning process that's a form a weak weak form of
intelligence when you learn kind of the physics
of a system and how to help it assist your goals
reinforcement learning in general is a really
exciting area lots of progress this is not going
as fast as many of the other fields but you know
humans no longer can be computers at chess or go
because of reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is getting uh to the point where it
can help us in robotic scenarios as well in
robotic Control Systems so this is a form of
imitation learning where essentially the robot is
trying to do this catch a ball in a cup maneuver
and with a little bit of human guidance and a
number of repetitions here's the policy after
15 trials it can actually do a decent job it
can get close to catching the ball in the cup
after 25 I think it's something like after 50
or 100 trials it'll actually be able to get the
ball on the cup it's not perfect yet but that's
actually pretty close to what I would call human
level learning rates if you give a ball and
a cup to a you know seven-year-old I bet it's
going to take them 50 or 100 times before they
reliably can learn how to get the ball in the cup
now they're not going to have to be against a
white background with a high resolution camera
mounted perfectly they're going to be able
to do this while they're you know walking
down the street or in a new environment but
still baby steps for the robot and there's
plenty of examples for every example of a new
Innovative reinforcement learning algorithm
actually working on a game or on a robot there
are a million examples of things failing this is
2015 so there has been a ton of progress you know
Boston Dynamics is way better than it used to be
but robots are hard robots are one of these uh
very challenging cases especially for machine
learning we'll talk about this later systems like
Boston Dynamics are largely physics-based models
painstakingly tuned learning algorithms struggle
in robotics and in the last five years there have
been major advances so it's not all just you know
falling over when it tries to open a door but
I just want to remind us that a very short time
ago this was an impossibly hard Challenge and the
field is moving very rapidly it's getting a lot
better but there's still a long ways to go good so
we've covered images we've covered language we've
covered Robotics and games I just want to point
out there are some things that are always going to
be hard they are mathematically hard and there's
no way around it so predicting chaotic systems
there are limits to what we possibly can do
regardless of how good the model is to how well we
can predict uh the evolution of a chaotic system
like the path of a hurricane or like what the
weather is going to be like next Thursday these
things are kind of hard by the mathematics and the
physics of the situation and so there is a bound
on how good you can do given certain measurement
fidelities and things like that there's also
caveats sometimes there are unexpected
consequences to our machine learning models
and so this is just a kind of cute example I found
where you know on Amazon let's say you want to buy
um this item I'll let you imagine what this item
is and it automatically suggests that you probably
want magnesium ribbon and aluminum powder in
addition to this item now I can tell you from my
checkered past that this is a suggestion for the
recipe to thermite so you know and and the reason
is is because this was a pattern that was in the
data enough people that bought this were actually
going to make thermite that this algorithm
suggests for you hey maybe you want to be making
thermite without thinking about the consequences
so there are certainly other dimensions to this
easy medium and hard there are things like
can we put you know uh guard rails on these
Technologies so that they don't give us unethical
or dangerous Solutions this is especially topical
now in the chat GPT and large language model
realm where you know there are real issues with
having these language models be as eloquent and
compelling as a skilled human what could go wrong
with that okay that's something we're working
on now but I think that understanding just the
landscape and the context of what is easy medium
and hard how fast these have changed over the last
10 years and what are the current challenges we
face today I think that gives us a good chance of
understanding how we can use these Technologies
where we need to develop these Technologies and
what are some of the ethical and kind of safety
critical ramifications of these Technologies
maybe just a parting thought for the engineers
in the audience for me one of the big exciting
Frontiers in this machine learning research is
taking all of these technologies that have been
developed for things like image sciences and
language models and transferring these over
into the world of physics systems governed by f
equals m a systems that have rules and guidelines
like aircraft or automobiles and you know for
me that's a really really exciting next task is
advancing machine learning to solve scientific
and Engineering challenges so of course that's
my personal prerogative and that's where you know
my lab works on our research but I think that is
going to be a really compelling set of examples
in the next 5 10 20 years all right thank you